this is a 2022 winter Marathon I'm not
going to stream the whole tournament I'm
already joining about three hours late
but I'll try and have some fun games
I'll try and play a variety of openings
and gambits try and get some staffords
try and get some rows and trophies
um if you are watching on YouTube in the
future
I do really appreciate uh those who
subscribe and comments let me know how
far in the video you make it and let me
know your favorite game
always nice when people leave timestamps
to their favorite games and moments
and now let's hop in and oh did that
work I think that worked
so I'm tied for last place I think I'll
start by berserking as many games as I
can and for those that aren't aware of
what it means to berserk uh this is a
special thing omnichas thank you in
Arena tournaments
where I caught my time in half but if I
win the game I'll get an extra
tournament point in the standings
ooh
oh what is this this is some
weird what is this it's like reverse
Kings Gambit
uh can I play this move
I'm just gonna leave all the tension
so I'm threatening okay
I think this is already like we're just
winning for white
yeah it takes and I'll win The Rook
Knights attacks the queen doesn't get
trapped in these lines
um the one calculation was Queen B4 but
then Knights D2 defending the bishop
and queen B2 Rook B1
so now the goal is to win
before move 15.
I'm two moves away from mate
oops
okay let's take a
Knight
it's really close to me here
the queen just wants to venture to af7
or the bishop wants to come to F7
okay I'll start attacking the king
can I win before move 15.
a pressure is on
Queen E8 Bishop D7
let's play this move I think some fun
having a little bit too much fun
I still don't see the meat though
okay I might as well win this bishop
okay I want to feed and cattle my Bishop
on B7 control the long diagonal
and also triple attack
oh and it's a fork
okay I failed to win before move 15 but
well I guess I'm succeeding and having
fun
okay let's discover a check that's a
free rook
and so many belated Christmas presents
thank you James block
uh
where's my meat
Jack
can I castle with mates
Chuck
oh no
come back here
I'm preserving castling with mates
because that would be a funny way to
start the tournament
but the king is running the wrong
direction
[Music]
oh maybe it's running the correct
direction
okay we'll get the G4 mate
hey it's the purple King
do people see that for a very brief
moment it was a purple King
because I pre-moved on top of the king
and it's um it's upon made so I think
that constitutes
as a rose and Jovi
yeah I do have a YouTube video from
earlier this year it's called the rare
purple King
moop soup has seen it probably oop soup
with a exact title in the chat
okay uh that was a nice start that's a
weird opening
it started with an England Gambit and
then
an attempted Danish gambits
and then kind of like a reverse Kings
gamut Falk beer counter Gambit okay that
was only the first games who
I got a very nice handmade chess set
clock and score book hoping to use them
for an in-person event in 2023. you
should come to Charlotte
we have the Charlotte command okay let's
play an England Abbott
uh
England Gambit declined
there's a Charlotte opening happening I
was about to say Charlotte opening
Charlotte open happening
[Music]
in a couple weeks just over two weeks
two weeks from now
um I won't be playing but I'll be a
special guest there
more information is in the chat
okay I should watch my time a little bit
but okay let's have some fun if takes
I'm gonna sack the knights
with idea of
Knight G3
so it takes Knight G3 I'll be attacking
the queen and the rook and defending the
bishop
oh no my knight
so here I'm hitting both Pawns
and I don't think white can defend both
Pawns
if on Diggs Knight I take on F2 and then
I deliver a fork
almost a fork meat
hmm
okay I guess I did take here the Queen's
tied down to defending the Rook
and it's still tied down if it moves
here I triple Fork
actually is a queen trapped
the queen is basically trapped here
Queen B3 I take the rook and
start harassing the king
foreign
resigns I'll I'll win in the first 15
moves
looking somewhat promising
oh
how to do this
uh Bishop D3
this move is attempting to paralyze
White
preventing castling
and I'll maybe go for the F Pond bush
wait did I missed a free night earlier
I guess if I took my bishoping
uh
[Music]
okay I'll take
some fun opening so far
I mean this was like another one of
these
weird Gambit declined openings but
opponent got in trouble pretty quickly
okay now the queen wants to go to each
one
slightly difficult
oh look at this move
this Rooks tied down to this and the
pawn was pinned to G2
okay that was pleasant
um I got the rating point for that
I think the strategy at the beginning of
the tournament is to
play Super aggressively
and
yeah I berserk the first two games so if
I didn't berserk either game I'd score
two points rather than three points for
each game
so berserking's just one way to
try and accelerate the
growth of my points
okay we have a uh appearance I'm playing
essentially a Grand Prix attack
against the purits
usually a setup I play against the
celian
oh I really want to take it's not a good
move though
let's just continue with standard play
like D3 Queen E1
usually the plan is to play Queen H4
and then like later F5
Bishop B3 attacking Queen
that's a nice benefit to King H1 it
gives a square for the bishop
maintain the nice diagonal
oh Queen H4
maybe I could have played Knight D5
first
it's a very feel good position
95 incoming
now the knights want to do some damage
here
starting with Knight E7
oh no my knight
there's too much fun I have three
attackers against F7
if H6 I probably take on a seven with a
rook
with a thread of Queen H6
also ideas of double Knight check mating
each five
still go for this
so now G6 is hanging
oh if Rook takes F7 I don't take back
I've played Knight takes G6
um
let's reinforce
foreign
yeah
young children close your eyes
double check knees
a king's attack twice and uh yeah there
is no escaping
rook's defended
that's a nice finish
thank you choco Roku
skiing oh greetings from Oman wow
I've never been to Sharjah
I went to the Dubai chess club
also Dubai Mall
as last year during the world
championship match
okay we have a walrus
it's one attempt to transpose into
Stafford Gambit
um what is this
I can play maybe I can play like a
delayed funny England
let's try it
I don't think there's oh no my knight
hehehe
wait a minute this doesn't work
oops
I thought it works for the dozens
will opponent find it
please don't find it yes okay
I'm in the clear
Bishop B5 would have won back the queen
it's a risk of trying to like
uh innovate in in an opening that
I wasn't familiar with also my Queen's
about to get trapped
let's play Let's play this move
also my King's about to get mated
thankfully I have this and okay I'm
winning the night
hey Eric oh hey akd
welcome back
wait what do I do rook d8 and if I take
those Bishop C5
maybe I just allow it
and the King will go for a small stroll
I don't deserve to win this game
given what I did in the opening
okay I'm up a queen verb Bishop
basically
my King has found safety
the biggest concern is time but
there's really no concerns after that
okay
uh that was a weird opening I wonder how
many people have tried this before
is this even the thing
leeches
so this position has occurred 77 times
12 clever people have played Knight E7
D takes Bishop F2 oh wow
and the the two games that featured this
position both both people found Bishop
B5
and white is actually just winning after
Bishop B5
okay
well that was a lesson learned
top 1900
four wins in a row
try and continue the streak
still waiting on the first offer Gambit
oh I still have to deliver on the
opening request too
each Bazi was cheering bits earlier
okay maybe we'll have a transposed
Stafford
thank you rookie mistakes
uh yeah this line is
it's a very natural move Bishop C4
but it runs into a lot of trouble really
quickly
and I've had this even against like
players rated 2200 Plus
um if you're not familiar with Stafford
it's
an easy line to walk into I think King
d8 is maybe the most accurate
this is also playable but
in I guess I can be fancy
oh adfast oh add fast spot has this line
in the book
does the book feature Queen H2 checkmate
okay
another Stafford victory that was nice
thank you Andrew gifting to AKA nurse
playing Bogdan veronchas
higher rated than my previous opponents
um I'm still berserking
I'm gonna have jobava London
and Joe Bava London this is a line that
I like to play
I originally prepared for Levy
also James Canty
um I think it's Knight C6
at some point I'm supposed to take
on F3 I think like maybe right away
thank you
it's actually a more stable position
than my previous games
hello to Will
um yeah I'll go for minority attack
does already go for a5b4
happy two years so Jay tonk
okay
very positional line like going for
uh just some creation of weaknesses on
the queen side
and Knight C4 should come eventually
we might see Queen A4 and then Knight C4
can turn Knight T2
that's so important for me to keep the
pace here
just not get too low on time
can you feature the Baghdad open oh dear
were you the one asking about this
earlier I don't think I've ever played
the Baghdad
at some point
I'll add that to the list
oh there's a silent each in Baghdad
a pleasant position
as both pawns are weak
not easy for white to find active play
I mean like B3 is an idea
if Rook C1 I probably just slide over or
slide back to B8
yeah threading Knight D2
could start with H6
foreign
wants to come to C4
it's hopping around
I think I can take this
G5
yeah it's all about not getting too low
on time
and just playing solidly
low risk chess
I can trade Rooks
I'll go through this Pawn the bishop can
never defend the pawn
it might be five
good luck in the tournament Eric
how do I attack the pawn Knight B3
coming
I'm just trying to gain time
or make my opponent's time bleed a
little bit
yeah this Knight is a little bit stuck
now
or oh there might be some funny mate
it's close
oop that sounds stalemate
everead berserk
ever what
read berserk is that a book
you can't say that I've read it
okay good game
I got some more berserking points
back determined so these are the opening
requests Italians
there once was a chess Pro named Rosen
whose skill was truly chosen he'd sit
for hours and think and never let his
mind sink until he found the perfect
mating position quack
that was beautiful
thanks for sharing that sucks here
I can't play an Italian or panziani
against the Sicilian
I could play I could play um
delayed alapin
she looks nice
now this is essentially
um a good version of a French for white
because Knight's developed to C3
out of five maybe coming
let's try with A3
some C4 idea
maybe C5 coming
okay pawns are smiling
there's a weird idea here okay let's
start by taking uh actually Bishop's E3
yeah I probably want to keep this bishop
as it's my good Bishop
G4 G5
there's an idea to play Bishop E2 Queen
D3 and then create the battery
I'll start by taking
okay staying aligned with the queen
oh
thank you
I could have taken but I feel like this
bishop can still do a lot of damage once
the queen comes to D3
another for the knights kind of in no
man's land
I could play Queen D2
and after Knight G2 King F1 the Knight
will be trapped
if G5 I am Busan
life is pretty good here
foreign
oh forgot the Rook defends a knight
should still be good
I suck
G5 first
I was so tempting to sack the queen
hmm
unleashing The Rook
yeah this is now some mating attack
before our hype
how you are well Eric
I'm very well in this position
[Music]
and the threat is Bishop G7
King G8 H7 checkmate
welcome back to Pizza racer
also this queen is hanging
okay got another Pawn mate
it was nice game overall
made some oversights got a little bit
low on time but
worked out in the end
okay
the games continue
should I play the Baghdad
so the Baghdad is
B
a
G
h
bag D
a
am I losing at
D is not a good opening and I berserked
and my Rooks attacks
why'd I do that wait I'm winning a
bishop no I'm not Bishop can escape
for a moment I thought that Bishop was
almost trapped
if we move back to B3
okay nice to catch you streaming you
keep me company during my night shift I
live in Sweden keep up the great work
thank you the Gap 90
well whoever wanted me to play the
Baghdad I hope you're happy
hopefully I can deliver
a win with it I've never played this
opening before
I still don't like the position
down the pond
low on Space it could be worse though
I'm pretty sure the Jalal about is much
better than the Baghdad
play like
G5 G5 is a move
okay I think things have stabilized a
little bit
and Rook d8
some kind of queen G6 E6
maybe A4 at some point
I guess we'll trade Queens
so I'm threatening to take
a potential pin and now I have the
lights words to work with
maybe I should have played A3
although it's probably good for me if
white plays A3
um
maybe move the king to G6
I want to play F5 and duck F6 oh that's
a free Bishop
okay no need for a duck
a duck still wouldn't hurt but
not necessary
yeah I think I gave my opponent a false
sense of confidence with the opening
it still takes work because the
position's so closed
a time to open things up
we're going to see Bishop F4 double
Checkmate that's a cool mating pattern
this Rook is uh
yeah also useful
taking away the E4 Square
okay
I think that's a second double Checkmate
of this stream
and the my first ever win was such an
opening
probably not as bad as a beach cafe
though
Beach Cafe is a bit more leathers
which translates to a bit more pawn
moves
okay so Baghdad I can cross off the list
now it's Italian time
Italian time
or ponziani
I think it was H bossy earlier asking
for
these um
these Italian and ponziani are a bit
more mainstream openings
okay we have
what started as a French
but not a traditional Fringe
I'm waiting for a block to Castle so I
can greet gifts
the ultimate holiday gift
opponent doesn't want a castle though
thanks for the Baghdad here are some
celebratory bits
oh thank you James Black
okay
well didn't quite Greek gift in this
game
uh there's no need to sack the bishop
I don't think we've had any E4 E5 games
with me playing White
had that one staffer game which was nice
thank you akd
okay berserking continues as long as I
keep winning I'll keep berserking
maybe I'll play O'Sullivan
another fun Gambit
uh
okay I'll play the squirrel I think this
is called the squirrel
the squirrel is not a good opening but
it's a cute furry creature
at least sometimes
uh wow look at this so the there's this
pin this pin arguably this pin to
like the d-pawn is positionally pinned
because after it takes takes
uh it's just good positionally for black
castle with check
and now there's some nice alignment
oh the squirrel is working out
beautifully I should have played Rook D4
would have won the Knight
missed opportunity
it's as if my Rook is a squirrel
climbing a tree
collecting nuts for the winter
night is like a bird it's building a
nest
in White's territory
foreign
this is a skewer
there's a funny line Knight H2 King G2 I
take take and then
uh first Rook F2 and then I take
now there's Bishop E3
my knight is kind of Trapped but I have
this move
threading the fork
and if takes I have the PIN
and that four is not legal because that
Pawn's pinned
I'm actually threatening this move
exploiting the double pin of the pawn
and Rook
requesting a king's or Evans Gambit
he'll Soldier comes first so I'll make a
note of that
okay
yeah this is not stalemate if white
didn't have pawns it would be stalemate
okay Evans gambits
Gambit or Kings Gambit
okay
I got some a lot of E4 E5 requests
yeah we can have a replay
I mean there were a lot of winning moves
but uh as a feel-good move because it
looks like E3 was covered but it wasn't
so nice start to the tournament
I've played 10 games 100 win and berserk
rate I haven't played any higher rated
players
my performance rating is still lower
than my actual rating
okay I'm playing E4
as long as I have more things to fulfill
uh
I can't get any of these opening
requests down
if I don't encounter E5
so I'm playing a wing Gambit
I'm trying to spread my wings
um
maybe D4 maybe another three
already some oh
opponent is flirting with Danger
okay threatening made in one
foreign
targeting this Knight
I want to be fancy
D4
I could play Queen H4 and win stuff
try and be a little bit fancier
I'm envisioning like a sack and then
Bishop F7
[Music]
there's some funny lines
foreign
H5
unfortunately this doesn't quite lead to
I don't think I'm threatening this
still not so I have G4
oh that's actually kind of cool like
this Knight will move and then I play G5
[Music]
and it still doesn't quite work
Play Bishop D3
I spent most of my time trying to find
the funny mate
I now have 29 seconds to try and finish
things off
still not meeting but it's looking
better
a G5
and where's the mating idea
foreign
this
it's one idea
oh
okay
thank you
I'm moving way too slowly
move a little bit quicker
kudos to block for surviving
not ready to lose my first game of the
tournament
Queen E6 yeah
I have six seconds left
there we go
this was maybe the closest game wow
like my opponent
played very provocatively early on
with this F6 move I spent most of my
time
looking for cool lines
okay
um back to tournament
so top a thousand
eventually my opponents will get like
higher rated once I kind of come into
the top hundred
uh berserk again
still trying to fulfill these these
openings
hey it's Levy what's up Levy
what is this
shout out to Levy up and coming
chess content creator streamer YouTuber
hope you're doing well
I have yet to take the my Chevy to the
levy
probably because I don't have a Chevy oh
no my Rook
foreign
material but isn't so bad
I can play this move
trying to win back a rook
also just trying to confuse my opponent
there's an idea to play Queen E4 Knight
D6
oh my opponents are the ones playing
crazy openings
I think that's half true and we're all
just playing crazy openings
I feel like I've slowed down a little
bit
but still trying to have fun
image about five
I want a soccer Queen
in Bishop by five
foreign
[Music]
so if Rook B7 I take the Knight and then
play Bishop F5 when The Rook
okay
here I win the Knight for free
ooh okay I can't resist
oh no my queen
I have a lot of material for the queen I
have Rook Bishop Knight and three pawns
for the queen
and now even a queen for the queen
that makes any sense
okay so the trick is to not stalemate
turning made in one
oh Vlog was also threatening made in one
good thing I'm I was a little bit
quicker there
uh back to tournament
pay top 500.
yeah I'm sorry to those who like cheered
bits requesting openings I've yet to
deliver
playing dead band
don't ban me for playing such an opening
I forgot what they call this this is
some sort of line
I'll just try and make things as weird
as possible this game
oh yeah the Mesopotamian Gambit
um
D6
the point of D6 was to defend the pawn
so I can
keep pushing my fling Pawns
did I play the GG opening I did GG
a very premature Gigi
usually comes at the end of the game
GG is like an egg
without an e
I keep pushing
this is unsettling because
this diagonal but I think it's okay
yeah there's any small children watching
like don't do this stuff that I'm doing
it's not good for you
even though it's kind of fun sometimes
Connect Four
pawns are grinning
I want to play D5 and uh C4
also want to teleport my knight to F3
maybe this Knight can eventually
maneuver
okay now I have the E5 Square which is
actually quite nice twitch often but
when I do it's an opportunity to Prime
something Eric
I appreciate that
yeah for those who are new to Twitch if
you have Amazon Prime
you can subscribe for free
it's uh easy way to support the channel
essentially gives me extra five bucks
for the month
thank you Mr master
okay so the King has run to the other
side
now they're still attacking potential
on the queen side
Maybe
threatening C4 now
Bishop C6 perhaps
probably should have played Bishop V6
the previous move
thank you Greg quack
I guess I caught a couple of people to
sub with Prime
make it three you rap Bandits
ubish would love a Smith Maura
okay I'll add that to the list
but first I gotta Focus here
I think everything's covered
hmm
in 94 at some points
thank you
hi Eric long time fan here hope the
chess is going well today oh thank you
Dan Marino
appreciate that
yeah I want to check me before White
flags
at this point it's difficult to do
the whole ceiling never too late to
Castle
okay
got the win that was a weird game that
was a weird opening I wonder at what
point in this opening was it a brand new
position
this position has been reached
over 11 000 times
but this position only two times
H4 was a novelty wow
it's crazy how many like just off the
openings have been played before
and the lead chest database
thank you chess rocks and Tatanka
or two new Prime Subs appreciate that
thank you phillius
oops
hi
I forgot to play um E4 my bad hey we
have a French
uh let's play a funny variation of
French C5 nether 3
or whatever this is
yeah the problem for black here is and I
can't really develop
maybe I'll go like full aggro on the
king side my favorite duck chess
streamer
oh thank you the Sheba
thank you moan saw Brigade
okay going full aggro
I have to take my anger out on someone
here
G4
I had Knight out of seven but
okay
the time has come
I don't think Rook f8 was called for
but yes it's working out
no mercy this game
yeah made in a couple more moves
yeah someday I'll try to play duck chess
with a real duck
we would need a really well-trained duck
that understands notation
time is a free queen that game an iPad
do I keep meaning to play E4 and I'm
it's muscle memory taking over
I don't think it's possible to transpose
I guess if opponent plays England
I could transpose to uh like Danish and
then panziani
okay so we have
uh whatever this is
uh let's play Bishop G3
yeah this is kind of a more dry position
but
at least it's something new
or straight from the opening to the end
game oh no my opening requests I'm sorry
I I have a long time to make it up right
hopefully
It's just sometimes when I get tired the
muscle memory
is more powerful than
my willpower
foreign
[Music]
because uh the black pieces aren't too
coordinated
some confusion on the D file
I'm trying to maintain control over the
D file
my Rooks defend each other through x-ray
vision
uh yeah this is I mean maybe I'll start
with this
it feels weird to play a move like Rook
D7
thank you Lux deuce
you Briggs Keith
um yeah this move
so this hits a rook
must rest now good luck on 24 hours
the ufod man
get some rest yeah I know it's late for
some people
myself kind of included
oh
yeah this Rook is still defended by the
other Rook
that's the nature of X-ray vision
and now I could take with Knight
and everything stays defended
some cool geometry here
thank you akd
okay now I just have to watch my time
and my Rook maybe the king will just
walk up
I hope to visit in Charlotte any idea if
I'll be able to spectate if I'm not
entered
um
I imagine I'm not sure how it works
actually
but generally the answer would be yes
I've actually never been to Charlotte
I've never been to an event
run by Charlotte chess Center so
I've heard very good things about them
they should be spectator friendly
I'm excited to go
okay I gotta move quicker because
time okay the fork is helpful
no it's so close to meat it's made in
two
wow I have seven was made in two
that's nice
okay
staying undefeated
71 German points
oh opponent was working
uh
Let's Play album counter gambits
I think adfast was asking for this
earlier
okay now we have some kind of
I don't know what we call this
know my Pawn oh no my other Pawn
how to do this
King's a little bit shaky on E1
the Knight wants to come in oh there's
some funny smothered mate
not quite working though
unfortunately
uh
smothermate doesn't work
so neither before I Bishop B4 winning
the queen
in this move
if Knight F4 I play Queen A5 Kings E2
Bishop F5
wait I've missed a free Queen oops
but now white has two things under
attack
I confuse myself there
uh
okay this is really close to me actually
a B3 Bishop yeah this is
really really close
Knight D3 only legal move
okay let's double check
oh this is gonna be fancy
oh oh okay check
where's the fancy mate
you just push
okay
Rook takes E2 checkmate
uh that was a fun game
album counter gambits
that was Alvin counter gamma declined
though
but I insisted on the Gambit there
I've somehow managed to remember to
berserk every game sometimes I forget
yeah next game if I'm white I'll play E4
and I'll try and get one of these
Smith Morrow was asked for earlier
okay E4
ah Cairo Khan there are no Carroll Khan
lines
on the list of recommendations
so we have one of these
uh I think it's E5
it's been a while since I've looked at
these lines
looks Pleasant though you see for
um
he makes sense to open the position with
the bishop hair
but it's going to be more positional
Pawn's a little bit loose
F3
[Music]
maybe taking first
I threw anything Bishop about six now
I'm not getting much here
I might be a little bit worse actually
opponent's playing well
play this allowing Knight C3
[Music]
and then Rook A1 a rookie two
I want to double up somewhere somehow
Bishop is now kind of sad
playing really slowly
Gotta Move quicker
that's a good move
I'm in a lot of trouble here
ah
how bad is this
it's pretty bad
oh what to do
go my Rook okay
all good things must come to an end
ah
yeah if I want to play ball that game
I didn't get my uh
nice spicy Gambit that I'm used to
and I just got outplayed in that in game
okay uh do I berserk maybe I'll keep
berserking because it makes sense from a
point standpoint
although it's risky against
especially a strong player or high rated
player
okay E3
wow so this is like completely
symmetrical
maybe I'll play this in Bishop A5
yeah White's slightly better let's wake
up the tempo
Bishop D3 I think should have been
played there
a B4 I guess Bishop d8
yeah generally the king is happier like
towards the center
although Nate t5's coming
okay going for a double up
down about a minute
but it's an easier position to play
compared to the previous game
the thing is it's like very equal though
I'm gonna take a lot of patience
trading off a lot too there is a small
trap here 96 I take and then B5
not quite happening
I'll put the nylon D6
at least try to
probably Bishop F5
because my pawns are the d-pawn's fixed
on the light Square
makes sense to trade the lights for
Bishops
it's still very equal
I'm voting this already
okay this is some progress
the knights tied down
yes and each four and King F4
and progress is being made
I think white was playing a little bit
too safe there
and now is suffering some consequences
although it's still yeah it's still
really close to equal
take probably Knight C7
trying to keep some tension
yeah I'm gonna have the outside passer
which is nice
uh that's a move
to take
I think the king will just run back
catch the pawn
almost forgot about Knight p7 but
not a big issue
uh how to do this
I should not have allowed that
I gotta move a lot faster
I can't believe what I've done here
foreign
oh no
oh no I lost Seth
also something weird happened with my
volume
like it stopped making sounds
there's still no excuses for losing that
die of meat in the final
[Music]
like here it's almost made to
I was moving way too slowly in the final
stages there too
also this is some weird
I need to like win the pawn quickly
I just need to play Knight G3 and then
walk the king over
okay
not my proudest streak
I was prouder of the other streak
okay
dull
I keep meaning to play E4
I have to be patient though
I don't think I've played like a true
London yet
this is some kind of like Joe Bava
London hybrid
oh no my Pawn
black takes I win the queen
still a black takes I win the queen
I missed G3 there because G3 there's
Queen H6
okay trying to rebound
yeah this is like really really close to
winning
foreign
maybe not though
it still should be better
whenever 94 is played I take it with a
bishop
okay keeping pace
[Music]
um
I think now the plan is to March up with
each Pawn
each six I take and win G6
unfortunately I can't win the each Pawn
but it still feels like progress except
I just blunder D4
foreign
[Music]
try and use my queen
as a weapon
it takes patience
uh remind me later
foreign
not sure why I gave that pawn back
there we go
oops
oh no
this one's lagging I think are they
lagging
what's happening am I lagging
what just happened
I don't know what happened there I just
plundered my queen and the opponent
stopped moving
uh that was strange
I guess I'll take it I don't feel great
about that
but
what to do
at least I ended the losing streak
I was a weird way to win a game
okay let me remember to play E4
except I'm black in this game
played this opponent earlier
trying to remember the game
ah that was Alvin counter Gambit
that was a fun uh oppon's avoiding at
this game though
uh maybe go for Cambridge Springs
or whatever this is
and all these messages popping up
yeah let's uh let's stop running
predictions I feel like I was cursed by
that last one
foreign
[Music]
five
uh wow that's a check but thankfully it
doesn't do too much damage
um
so I have to be really careful here
though
foreign
the fatigue is kind of setting in
as I I did stream two hours of title
Tuesday earlier
I feel like I'm just playing more slowly
okay the king can come
yeah let's just try and trade stuff
I don't think white can avoid the trade
hey white should be a little bit better
here though
rookie seven
okay I'm playing for a win which means
I have to lose a pawn to not repeat
okay some activity
some imbalance going for Rook C2
okay this is
pretty uh yeah once I got the Rooks
doubled I was feeling pretty good
okay I still have my espresso there's a
coffee I
started with kind of forgot about
it's kind of bitter
but hopefully that will give me a boost
top 200. okay
I remembered
I remember to play E4
hey it's Smith Mora someone was asking
for smithmore earlier
um
I know a little bit of smithmore theory
like if Knight F6 I play E5
and then in these lines usually Rook T1
the ventral E5
Queen A5 I'm not familiar with
go after D6
wow
I mean a B4 I think Knight D5 as a
typical Planet oh I forgot to berserk
maybe that's a good thing though
I have um
a bit more time to work with
so the question do I take with bishop or
Knight
because D6 should come next probably
huh
you'll take with knights
threatening this and G6
so we might see King f8
oh although D6 isn't a huge threat
because Queen takes Queen
name maybe Queen E2
okay so now it's a big threat
it's really hard to stop
Bishop's pinned supporting D6 with my
own Bishop
and queen C4 is coming
and I don't see how black defends F7
the Knight H6 I take it
Queen z7 I take it
oh that move oh that move I have this
move
obstruction of the seventh rank
I could have taken the bishop but t7 is
a a bit fancier
I'd imagine the engine would give force
made here
because there's really no stopping this
even ideas of Bishop D6
promoting
so Smith Mora I can
move
on the list
oh black is still surviving though kind
of
it's really close
um
Chuck
I'm not immediately winning
somehow black screamed away
not sure how that happened
okay if Rotex Brook is made in one
I can take this first
and then take
okay
okay keeping some kind of streak
streaky tournament so far
so Smith Mora can be moved to the list
of Plato openings
just realized my event list was a little
bit off
uh let's play E5
wow oh it's a vampire Gambit
I think Levy was the first one to
introduce us to the world
huh
interesting
there's another game I forgot to visit
but that's again probably a good thing
um
wow
I wonder if this is some kind of theory
it's like Queen of six but Queen F6 is
already G4
huh
I take can't take
I've stumbled into something here
in Queen E7
and D5 is a risky move I'm inviting this
this d-pawn might be lost
casting is coming
start by taking
very risky position here
some funny line like Queen A4 and Knight
C6 takes us Vision Queen E2 mate
I think I still
probably go for taking
I blundered Bishop B7
light misses it
now with Queen C4 I take on E2
I think a lot of things have been missed
so far
but it looks
looks like if I can just take the
rooking castle
should be okay for black
oh did I miss a queen trap
I can go back and look later
okay this looks pretty safe
I might see D5
I just want to trade
Rook D1 probably C5
hmm
still tricky though
Bishop H3 Knight D7
oh I messed up
but how bad is it
foreign
[Music]
so previously white could have taken
take on them B7 here I don't think it's
as bad
it still looks scary
should be okay
hmm
if I take and play B6
yeah like if I get the time I want to
play King D Knight C5
there's still a lot of compensation here
you can have six
if I need to take
[Music]
um
I'm in trouble
it's gonna come down to time
okay so rook and jupons for two Bishops
let's Splendor her Rook there
oh no I've gone through the road
opponent doesn't take it though
oh no I blundered a rook again
hey I made a queen
okay
oh what a
what a game
I think I need a small break after that
game
good to see you back oh good to see you
too Rocky 50 move sequence is when white
moves and then black moves one move or
two thanks
um in chess one move is a move for
lightning move for black
so one ply is considered
um like King A4 is one ply
and jooply make up one move I hope that
answers things I know it's a little bit
confusing
but 50 moves would be
as it's seen here so move 1 through 50
is
a move for each side
someone was saying I missed some Queen
trap
I'm not sure where though
I didn't take because after it takes uh
Brooks defended and it hits these things
I wanted to check my reading before the
tournament
okay I've lost seven points
not too bad though
top 150
out of almost 9 000 people
I've been live for 90 almost 94 minutes
trying to close in on top hundred
I forgot to berserk the last few games
I'll play E4
okay another Smith Mora
worked well that previous game
a Z5 already a move
E5 is a move
yeah this looks dangerous for black
about how
it's coming this first
I want to play this and this
yeah like is why it's taking time there
hmm
I'm not sure if this works it looks
interesting though
check
and then I probably take but which thing
to take
there's also 98 wow
I'll take the Rook
Bishop f2i win the bishop
and I'll beat up a piece
okay that was a funny line
E6 is now weak just got to connect six
ask me anything
oh congratulations
how did it feel
I don't think I've gotten connect six's
tournament
oh wait let's be careful
it's a good move
I'm losing back material man
um
oh this takes a lot of work to win too
oh no
I have messed up
or did I
uh I messed up
what to do
okay my Bishops do work
foreign
work
yeah what to do
oh I got a little bit too low in time
allowed 94 94 was a good move
yeah the first thing to like realize is
a threat after nine of six
game
there goes some streak again
but that had less to do with berserking
and more about just
seeing simple tactics
don't worry I'll be posting this full
term to YouTube
assuming it can properly like export and
upload
okay
Stafford gamut time
or bush gasket time or just an Italian
Maybe
just an Italian
hey we got an Italian
but from the other point of view
foreign
being a little bit ambitious here
idea Bishop E7
can I sack a queen
how bad is it
it's pretty bad yeah let's not sack the
queen
I'll just accept the fact I'm down
a couple pawns or no just one pong
I'm tagging the bee Pawn
can't really take it without allowing
Knight D7
it still feels like there's some
compensation here
six still
an idea
good move
hmm
thank you
also a weird formation
happening
this should be okay
[Music]
um
there we go
oh no
ah
that's not stealing because King G2
oh what to do there goes some reading
I guess I haven't lost a game without
losing two games in a row
so
whenever I guess whenever I have a
result it happens multiple times in a
row
right to Evan
okay let's try and reverse momentum
um maybe I'll play in Italian
because it works so well just now
against me
hey it's Italian time I'll play C3 and
then D3
um
go for castling first
and before
foreign
typical for Italian the Knight will find
its way to E3
and maybe I'll start with Bishop E3
um
yeah we both have Knights and a similar
structure but
with Knight H4 I'm going to be the first
one to
like generate some activity
uh F4 is an idea
they're probably worth
um yeah trying to open that file
The Rook back
oh
yeah my queen wasn't defended this would
be possible
ooh
a spicy move
I think I can play F4
it's getting really spicy though
yeah this is one big trade
so Queen G5
oh wow
on G5
it's actually very smart from Black
because F4 yeah
and G5 is still defended
and Black's playing as well
only go for H4
only addressing all my threats
okay down the pawn
I'm losing E4 but trying to make some
progress
on the king side losing a lot of bonds
here
the thing about the pawn diamond
light squares are not being controlled
wow
opponent offering the draw
attacking a rook and the pawn
I think I'm happy I turned down the draw
it still takes work though
given the time
okay we force the queen trade
okay
not an easy game
I'll take it
I gotta play like most of that game and
then opponent blunder The Rook
so
life goes on playing legitimates
I'll play E4 again
it's still due for a panziani
maybe okay maybe a bishop B5 check
and then
oh what's a line castle in the E5
Quincy it's the main move Queen C7 walks
into some trouble
because Bishop 4 comes
I think it's still playable though
I have some vague memories of the sign
like Knight C3 maybe Knight A3
just so I can access C4
yeah winning material
a nice little opening
as we've seen before it still takes a
lot of work after winning material
uh the main goal is to simplify
three
King F2
also a matter of just addressing what
black wants to do
defining this now
here's an idea to like lift the rook and
attack the pawn
foreign
yeah I kind of just played A3 without
any purpose
some idea
here we go
now that I just put H4 and then win the
pawn
oh fancy
I played G4
defending
defending the Rook threatening to take
also preparing King G2
I do allow Rook H2 but then King E3
I think this is okay another four I just
take it
foreign
Block's resisting though
wasn't easy
I was close got the job done
oh man
approaching 100 tournament points
playing the fellow ion so double is
working
um
I'll play I'll play Stafford
I played this opponent a bunch before
the fall pure counter gambits
wait this is not a line
or is it
maybe it is
it doesn't look right though
yeah there's no way this is good
oh no
I've botched the opening
maybe it's still playable
take
going after the d-pawn
or one of the d-pawns
if I can win the d-pawn it's probably
not so bad
still looks terrifying
rookie one I take
offering the queen trade
um
oh wait what I don't know what my mind
was on
who is focusing on there
what I think the g-pawn was hanging
okay that's a nice gift
thank you
ah what's I do I just dropped a rook
in a completely fine position
[Music]
as maybe fatigue setting in
I think the pawn was hanging
I was like calculating rookie seven
what should I do
okay
still top 150.
it's gonna take a lot of um
changes in my level of focus here
wake up bits oh yeah thanks for the wake
up bits
okay going back to bread and butter
opening
opponents immediately Falls for this
trap
foreign
the sad thing is it's not like so simple
I might even like already be worse
it should be really sad
because my night's trapped
I think this is still okay
very questionable though
I should have played B4
can still consider B4
so I'm threatening like this takes a
night here
not gonna happen
okay
foreign
[Music]
Rook D5 but then there's Rook A1 check
okay
not my proudest series of games
hey this these patterns still continue
though
the problem is that losing streaks are
getting more frequent I just have to
control the tilts
maybe maybe I should take a break from
berserking
but no breaks from Stafford gambits
I think this was only the second
Stafford
this tournament
uh why am I forgetting Queen D6
I work out for one has a line
yeah this opponent has studied their
stuff
although I think this was already
like playable for black
wow
it was busy before and then Knight F4
this looks playable
um
there's Rook G1
I have to take
this a little bit unsettling
I can't Castle
be this first
this is losing but I'm
I'm taking a Gamble
or is it losing
yeah it's losing
I should probably just resign
opponent moves a little bit too quickly
there though quack quack quack good luck
in the tournament quack thanks I'm gonna
need a little bit more luck
maybe a few more Quacks
my time
there would be three and A3
a good move
yeah what to do oh no my reading
I don't think I've been this low in
Blitz in a long time
have a great new year I think you might
see it with love from New Jersey
New Jersey
oh that's probably how people in New
Jersey pronounce Jersey
okay
um let me try and crawl my way out of
this uh
slump
yeah part of it is like being more
focused moving a bit quicker
not blundering
staying awake
foreign
so this is a very typical London
position
there's a few plans I mean one is A5
another is somehow to exploit F7
I think Bishop C4 eventually Knight G5
but The Bishop's undefended so
yeah the pawn is pinned
and D6 is a bit looser now
Play Bishop B5
that pressure is building up
hey rookie one first leave the tension
um
Queen B5 hitting the Rook
some idea to play Knights
B4 it's a D3 and then
have better control
yeah this is a nice setup for the pieces
and then eventually I want to like move
the Knight away from F3 and then play
Pawn F3
thank you
all the point of three here it looks a
little bit too weakening
but eventually
and finally chasing the Knight away
uh Rook here
I should have taken
uh oh
am I losing
won't hurt me
I don't know what's going on here
actually
seems really close to getting mated
I'm hitting these things and this thing
now I'm trapping the queen
assuming I'm not getting muted
oh wow what a move
I should have taken the other night
okay what a game it's a very clever idea
though this Knight G4 move if I take the
queen I get mated
wow
did I miss a simple tactic
oh I miss Bishop takes B8 ah
okay I need to see simple tactics
okay at least I'm changing the momentum
hopefully this will be the beginning of
some kind of streak only 18 hours and 54
minutes to go
I don't think I've had a Budapest at
least Budapest accepted
here I'll play a London playing this
line This is gaining some
popularity
I had this earlier in a title Tuesday
game
objectively this isn't so special for
black but It's Tricky
like B3 E5
I think this is playable too
Knight C3 there might be four
so I'm throwing Knight C2 also having to
take and then Knight C2
foreign
just blunder the queen
that's probably a time I should stop
let's see if I can come back though
kind of like I'm giving Queen hugs
also that's a good sign
the bishop could have moved
oh no my queen
maybe it was just a very deep long-term
sacrifice
because in this position it's impossible
for me to plunger a queen again
the one benefit of not having a queen
you can't blunder something you don't
have
seems like a fair handicap to me
but unfair to me
I played this move
getting some initiative
I'm gonna play Rook d8
there's actually like crazy compensation
here
Rook D the knight's pinned
Rook B2 coming
okay Bishop wants to activate
Queen side down to defending the Knight
problem is I'm still down on time and
still down the queen
those nights doing weird things
and Knight D4 maybe at some point
hey this move first
Bishop defends
Ah that's a good move
what's the damage
still have the bishop here
never resign when you have the bishop
pair
foreign
passer
what is this position
still crazy compensation
ah there's Bishop C4 but then I take
it's not so simple
foreign
both Rooks attacked
I could have taken the knights
ah what to do
oh
[Music]
uh had some chances
even
okay maybe allowing Knight p7 is the
final straw
I can't take the Rook because I'm down
so much material I can't afford to trade
um
my one chance was to take the Knight
here
which is still losing but what to do
okay note to self
don't give away free Queens
hey I'm still above 2500.
chug the espresso perhaps Chuck the
espresso
every time I lose a game I'll take a sip
if I lose like five in a row then I'll
chug
um
memberserking is still probably plus EV
my problem is more that I'm blundering
pieces
not that I'm like flagging
just a secondary problem
oh I want to have fun so there's a line
with Knight T4 eventually
okay and this is a playable position
E4
now Knights are giving me a little bit
of trouble
things still look controlled
foreign
[Music]
let's play this first
it's almost a cool idea to take
oh no I blundered
bad blender too
poem's offering me a draw
wow I mean Knight B6 would have like one
material
when the draw offer came I assumed my
opponent saw it
but I guess not
I mean it's still a little bit worse for
black but it's playable
okay we're trading I'm gonna get Rookie
two at some point
after trade
which means I should win back the pawn
although maybe not
it's already a little bit tricky for
whites
um
yeah this is more effective
okay so now I went from being much worse
to being up upon
in a rook ending now
winning more Pawns
The Rook does not want to be passive
foreign
but I guess it was a game
yeah there's some eventual zigzbong
hmm
yeah no stalemate traps
now white should probably play this
hoping I pre-move like Rook D1 or C1
like one last Stanley trap
okay
let's see uh
and see if I can regain some momentum
and stay above 2500
back in the top 150
I have not yet broke the top hundred
I did play in Italian earlier let me
switch this
let me play um let me play one of these
candy gambits
or not a Gambit just uh
unpleasant opening
yeah being a bit more aggressive than
usual
I guess this is the usual aggressive
aggressiveness though
not castling
and going of her uh the quick King's
side attack
allowing F6 to
F6 Queen H5
request to play botes Gambit I've
already uh done that a few too many
times as tournament
unwillingly
oh okay so this is Interactive
I take first it's important to seize
initiative
and also sees a moment
carpe diem
okay
I'll take it
and some people have played way more
games like the person in 125th
has played so many more games
which I guess is an interesting term in
strategy
so more games that you play the more
points you can potentially Rock up
which is one of the strategies with
berserking and it's not good for reading
or like result or quality but
it's kind of what the
format incentivizes with Arena
tournaments
okay so here we have like the key
critical line of Stafford
I think this is the third Sapphire
Gambit
uh Bishop E6
oh no my Bishop
Knight D2 is a good move or Knight D2
still runs into this
yeah this can get tricky
because my D2 is still okay
wow
can I sack everything
I want to take on F4 next
maybe I'll start with check
I didn't fully calculate this it looks
fun
lights pinned if takes it's looks like
some kind of horse mate
or at least winning material
okay that's a free Queen
foreign
played what is recommended as like um
refutations Bishop F3 move
but um yeah the lines are still very
tricky
especially in fast time controls
yeah this is a meeting very soon
Queen F3 also a threat
foreign
moving up in the world
still staying above 2500.
back on the berserking streak
playing Neptune 2069
um let's play a safer opening
so we have uh I guess this is like a
carocon panov
Ina
playing G6
E6
don't fully understand Knight P5
have to be careful though
that E5 takes takes I win the knights
like we trade a lot
and these squares are a little bit
unique
hello not a GM welcome back
happy three years
36 months
yeah this is very typical for like a
carocon
um
maybe 97. I have to watch out for this
Square it's 94.
okay now I can take
winning a pawn
Diamond might be happening very soon
a five
a five would be a nice move to get in I
don't know if I can make it happen
though
clingy four is coming I have this move
I still want to play F5
and this first
Queen G4
moving way too slowly
hey Eric thanks for your consistent
effort in bettering chess I'm working on
getting my rating up just about to reach
1 200 in Blitz nothing crazy I have been
doing the London system for the last
year thanks to you any chance you could
sorry you got cut off
um
I'll try and read that at some point
later
when I'm not in time travel
I do appreciate the message though
look at these Pawns
such Godly Pawns
okay
what a game thank you kangaroo
recommend a second opening for your
reading
um Queen's Gambit Queen's Gambit
Kali E4 English there's so many openings
to choose from
um sometimes it's a matter of
finding games that inspire you and then
playing the openings from those games
okay
hey
I just like leapfrog a bunch of people
80th Place now
okay playing life of Ryan
speaking of Queen's Gambit
I'm not playing a Queen's Gambit
playing uh a banoni
playing a Banco oh what's uh what's so
cool I think in subango
is it takes and then
it's like
uh
what's this right no
it's E4
there's like a frappe Coca-Cola thing
I forget the line
I think I've already like messed it
up for
yeah I've
okay we're just having like a normal
Banco I guess
I don't usually play these structures
looks okay though
I'm giving some serious time odds
so Bishop C3 I have A3
and this move is making my opponent
think too
which is good
and get back a little bit of time
and Knight D4 Queen D3
strange position
Knights are doing some acrobatics
each four at some point
I really want to play this move but then
it doesn't work
and G3
another idea is Knight C4 E5
really
still no it's evil material now
this doesn't look good if lock plays
correctly
take
I guess Rook takes I take with Queen
because I can't allow Queen E3
I think black missed some opportunity
there now E5 is an idea
yo
this is looking
promising now
because E6 may be coming
trying to soften the king side Pawns
and the queen is going to maneuver to
like F5
foreign
yeah still looks ugly
oh
hmm
my dog's Murphy Nash and Memphis say hi
and wolf oh woof
who's a good boy you're a good boy
hello whoever rated appreciate it
hey okay dirty flag hey it's Nemo what's
up Nemo
shout out to Nemo so yeah if you're just
joining I played 36 games so far
I've lost about 50 rating points I've
been berserking a lot
I'm having some fun games I'm currently
on a five game winning streak
berserking will continue
oh thank you is AZ
I'm gifting to Nemo
I still have some openings to fulfill
from earlier
uh let's play an ortho shop
so the orthostop Gambit is Queen B3
it's a cool line against the French
because many cases it leads to an open
position
and usually French players like closed
positions
Knight C6 is a good move
or is it
I had this move
all right now I'm just kind of making
things weird
uh D3
wow
good move
yeah queen queen F4 is not a good move
uh what to do
G7 is already defended
so I'm probably losing another Pawn
it could be worse though
92 castling
I've definitely had worse positions
and that's easy to say but uh
okay I'm just playing down the pawn
uh got the two knights
Knights are sometimes nice for fast time
controls
they create trickier possibilities
and preventing the G4
some idea Knight F4
oh
the unexpected gift
still takes a lot of work
Knight D4
I can't quite defend that
wow
foreign
idea
okay
hmm
foreign
terrifying draw
wouldn't mind a draw here
died blunder the night
I really wouldn't mind the draw but
a little bit too late
I had my chances
H3 actually got very weak so maybe I
should have
I should have just traded and played H4
use the horses
I didn't uh didn't make the press the
best practical decisions that game
okay playing Just chess pause
never played before
um offering still a Stafford
will have an Italian
[Music]
hey I'm still not below 2500
try and rebuild the rating
yeah tournaments like this
generally
can lead to bleeding a lot of rating
you see 65.
it's also G5 G4 could be a cool idea
foreign
Bishop moves I win the pawn and if takes
takes and I'm getting in Pawn E4
so we might see like G4 at some moment
the Charlotte open is hosted within
walking distance of my parents house and
only 30 minutes from where I live hope
to see you there oh nice also happy
upcoming New Year smile
looking forward to meeting you in person
Hi Jinks
it's cool
yeah again we have the Charlotte
commands I'll be
visiting a real-life chess tournament in
a few weeks
more information
[Music]
will be linked if you use the commands
yeah this takes patience
also takes a bit of speed
don't think there's a way to defend H3
without keeping E3 defended
[Music]
not exactly what I wanted I thought I
was not or I was thought I was saving F7
opponent offering a draw
actually wait
What's Happening Here
's the White's playing for a win
oh it's playing for a win
okay
oh no my reading I fell below 2500. at
least I have a goal now
to get back above
yeah not the best uh
in-game technique I was very close to
losing that though so I should be
grateful
so 121
and leaders
I mean top 10 is still very far away
okay we have a Budapest accepted this
might be the first Budapest except to
this stream
against the fellow I am
I usually don't play uh this D6 Queen F6
against Knight C3
but it makes some sense
I guess this is a move
King E2 coming
you know the problem for white is after
Queen D2 I win The Rook otherwise I win
F2
thank you
but am I meeting
or is this funny move
takes and then it's a pork
because the pin and the fork
so King D4 it's kind of funny Queen B2
while the game
[Music]
trying to calculate mates
I guess Queen B6
and then C6 checkmates
yeah just to show
uh if King Z5 it's made into after this
and then this
is a fun game
yeah I think white should play Queen D2
or dc7 White's plus three wow
that's a dubious gamut
but I guess it can be effective in Blitz
okay
hey at back over 2500
so I'm still trying to satisfy these
requests
but we need people to play E5 in
response to E4
King's Gambit Maybe
I'm playing the so-called McDonald
attack
transposing into Grand Prix
foreign
C4 could be a little bit irritating
takes in B3
foreign
this is playable actually
oh wait G3 is no no longer defended
uh yeah that was a clear mistake
can still be confusing
take this
it was very confusing
so the takes I take
foreign
all right
F5
I have to move quicker
[Music]
foreign
oh no
even towards the end
what to do
oh no my reading
yeah this won't be a 24 hour stream
still top 100 which is kind of nice
but
a lot of grounds to make up
no more berserking at least for this
game
I'll take on e4
yeah this is a actually a crazy line
the opponent doesn't know this line
which is nice Bishop C4 is the main move
there
foreign
Traveler
I appreciate the energy
foreign
yeah this is still looking very suspect
okay I wonder
like D4
not really threatening to take but
it's a way to preserve the pawn
oh dear
the key seven
not a good position
I mean A2 is hanging
I'm kind of just confused looking at
this position
[Music]
I think it looks okay
I mean things could go very badly very
quickly
thank you Albano
you F7 is vulnerable
[Music]
play something like
even F6
looks really really risky
question of the befits of t
I assume you're asking about benefits of
t
um
yeah it's just kind of a
a way of staying calm
it's also tasty
I'm pretty sure there's a lot of health
benefits too
antioxidants sometimes you get that
caffeine boost
other times it helps you sleep
so I'm threading this I'm threading made
into
so which king is less safe
it feels good having more time in the
opponent
oh a bun says first time catching your
stream nice
nice well thanks for watching on Twitch
yeah it looks like I can check and check
and win the bishop
oh it's not so simple
throw in some Knight B3
also had Rook d8
hmm
yeah this first
I'm trying to keep the king in front
wow
what a weird position
[Music]
threading this and then some Fork
doesn't quite work though
past pawns must be pushed
oh wow
that move I missed
okay
uh it came down to a dirty flag
wow
uh
all tickets
24.99 again
one spot above the champion
okay
I'd like to get into top 50.
I would also like to satisfy these
opening requests
I played a lot of different things
against Sicilian
now it's time for this line
a little checkmate
um
you like B4
I'm just trying to make up a Gambit here
it's probably dubious but
it looks kind of interesting
the A6 I take
at Pawn digs I'm thinking about Rook
takes
foreign
back
or I guess black didn't accept the
gambits
so now we have a position
it looks playable
oh
start with this
hitting E6
and Knight G6
yeah a lot of compensation here
yeah I think if I lose again I'll I'll
take a break like an extended break from
berserking
but again it's part of the Arena
strategy
okay threatening made in two
um
okay so one of these pawns should be
falling
happy subiversary to me thanks for all
the great content Eric
oh there you twigger tweet
okay so it's still equal material
Queenie six this is well placed here
foreign
Rook T6
trying to calculate
potential socks
foreign
this should be okay
okay 2500 on the dots
top 60
here we go
about 18 hours left
playing Little Pond friends
man a lot more Sicilian players
than E5 players today
playing this line I haven't played this
one in a while
uh that's a free night
a nice opening
I'll go for the quick attack too
like Knight G5 and
Target H7
so F6 runs into Bishop C4 check
ooh
ooh fancy
take take
other piece I shouldn't lose this
it's a matter of consolidating
and simplifying
the thing is I've lost like similar
positions to this
earlier so
my confidence is not an all-time high
but things are still under control
oh no okay I thankfully have this move
the kingdom it's gourmet's way out king
wants to be on E3
if I didn't have Rook D1 I'd maybe be in
some trouble
foreign
no need to take the bishop
maybe eventually I will
maybe I'll take the Rook
okay
that was nice
top 50.
gradually climbing and so the berserking
is working
also leads to quicker games
we'll play the Four Knights
Center fork trick
yeah this line is known to be
a bit questionable for white
I think Knight G1 is probably best
I'm already threatening some kind of
push
um
take
I guess taken than this
this is a maiden two threat
like if if Rook B1 I take on C2 and then
Rook D1 checkmate
so that went sour for that really
quickly
or sour for whites
having some color identity issues
um
I guess we trade
hitting the bishop
I guess my opponents are also tired
like some people have been playing this
tournament for a long time
I'll take it
question could you please recommend an
opening for me to play I'm 16 to 1700
rated
okay I'll recommend whatever I play in
this game E4
it's a good opening control the center
um
yeah when you play E4 you have to be
ready for a variety of
different defenses
but it teaches you a lot of like
good basic principles of chess
um
Bishop ticks was also possible
did you Friday hungry
and going for this interesting idea
Queen A2
so I forgot to berserk this game
which is probably a blessing in disguise
thinking about Knight H4
idea not a five
because G6 would hang the pawn
foreign
building a pressure against D6
a files now open
okay seven
might as well include it
It's Tricky though
p904
Bishop B6 idea
yeah it's getting spicy
if I take
wow
foreign
[Music]
interesting position though
Rook B7
oh
[Music]
yeah I'm in some trouble
good move
I guess F3
man this is desperation
but F3 might allow me to hold on for a
bit longer
like Rook F1 is already some idea
the problem is my knight is really
misplaced
I have some kind of
Queen A7
some interesting geometry here
Queen E3 I guess King age one
it still looks terrifying
okay
if I'm down the pond
dark Spurs are a bit problematic
train
Knight B6 is some idea
foreign
still surviving
don't meet me
ah
don't make me
all opponents didn't make me
some accomplishment
I was fortunate to survive like F3 saved
me for a bit
well played though
still top 50.
There Goes My streak
maybe I should have berserked
yeah I think in general berserking is
still like plus EV
IL You'll Play some
more normal opening
we have a London
a solid line
foreign
classic minority attack
I just hung upon
opponent doesn't take it though
okay slowly but surely
I essentially want to double up on the
first rank
like Rook BB one coming
thank you
that's a funny sweater for the king
I'm not mating yet
it does feel close
in Queen F6
oops
foreign
[Music]
F6 is coming
should be meeting
that was a weird game
foreign
back over 2500.
36th place
over 10 000 players in this tournament
hi Eric if you could give one thing to
every person in the world but never have
it again what would you choose oh
maybe my each Pawn
and then that way I would forever have
an open H file
or maybe
I'm not sure
maybe a night
I kind of like Knights
okay E4
hey okay King's Gambit
uh I can finally cross off a suggestion
I forget who asked for this earlier
someone was asking for it
also I don't know what I'm doing here
but maybe it's a line
is this a line takes
oh dear I feel like I'm stumbling into a
theory that I'm not prepared for
E5
some words
I appreciate the words
okay so we at least we have a fun King's
Gambit
I'm not sure who this is going to be
more fun for
I have two pawns for the piece
the black has the two Bishops
Jack
I think that move was missed
Now The Rook survives
I can take Dole I forgot the bishop or
the bishop it's a rook
or hits my king ah
it's still not over this is a threat and
Knight F6 is maybe coming
I'm down two pieces though
okay
Chuck
E7 or D7
and this should be losing but it's
not 100 clear
wait what
that was a really nice gift
foreign
though with 17 seconds
also thank you Irene
gifting five appreciate that
What's Happening Here
uh let's play this
okay
making some progress
let's go
a lot of weird King's gathered
oh man
foreign
oh man okay
that was
I don't think I'm gonna play that
opening again
at least I woke me up a little bit
okay I finally played King's Gambit
okay
how about this I'm Gonna Keep playing
until I lose and then I'm gonna take a
break I feel like I'm due for a break I
haven't taken a break yet this stream
and we are approaching a three and a
half hour mark
still trying to deliver on panziani and
Evans Gambit
playing High rate player in eighth place
maintaining a 2600 plus rating
and knob is working back oh dear
I might be taking a break sooner than
expected
oh this is what Carlson played against
me
uh it's slightly unsettling
foreign
this is already as questionable opening
I just take this
probably not good but
it's worth a try
hmm
wow
what is this
I'm hanging upon
because Pawn is maybe weak
depending that
sort of takes a check and then take on
G1
oh except I can't take uh
oh it's a fork I thought I plundered I
won the Queen instead
so that kind of worked out I think this
okay this simplifies
yeah my opponent is probably also a bit
fatigued
also this still isn't over like this is
not easy to win
check
foreign
[Music]
or the d-pawn
foreign
no break
oh
there's moments
like I was so fixed fixated on taking
the rook and then taking the bishop
but then I saw 94.
okay
that was the first time beating someone
higher rated than me in this tournament
I think
it was working again
hey double berserk
our last game was a wake up
now trading already traded a lot here
reaching ungame territory
um
probably close to a draw
not sure if I can grind this Elite
School 21 months good luck
meets goo
[Music]
offering some trades
that's a good move
foreign
pressure here
should still be a draw
and while it's taking time though
no I'm in trouble
oh what to do
draw
foreign
oh no my king
oh
yeah there are a lot of things missed I
think towards the end of the scheme
at some point I should have been a
little bit more cautious
also I should have gotten counter play
like G5
what to do thank you Gary
okay it's break time
yeah it's 12 27 am for me
so I'm gonna go on a small break
and
then I'll return
here we go
I got some coconut water
which will hopefully wake me up a little
bit
not so much caffeine in coconut water
and here we go
Gary says we behaved okay
that's good to hear
so I still want to get a ponziani and
Evans Gambit
oh
Sicilian it is
ah we played earlier
G6 okay let's go for H4
H5
um
I think I just take this
essentially calling the bluff
yeah the knights tied down to the other
night
not anymore
it's D5 Square looks nice
and queen was almost trapped
a little bit awkward
foreign
getting out of the PIN
and now Knight D5
oh
yeah so the button is pinned to the
bishop
there's Bishop takes
with knights
attack
as not sure if this does much
it's interesting though
the E4 should hang
foreign
[Music]
a little bit wrong there
oh
okay now it's getting spicy
okay
I'll take it that was a little bit
topsy-turedy
oh cool grapes is dropping out of the
tournament oh no
it's all our tournaments yeah at some
point
it's sometimes important to get some
sleep
okay we have an orthostnop again
my last Ortho snob wasn't so successful
so
we'll see how this one goes
thank you
hmm
okay attacking the pawn
thank you
yeah this G6 Square looks very
appetizing especially for the knights
which unfortunately I no longer
have the F3 Knight
but I am up the exchange
the king will essentially artificial
Castle
one idea is to play like Queen G6 Queen
H7 checkmate
oh no my knight
wait this is maybe not so great
what have I done
look at this first
foreign
[Music]
wow
wow oh man
okay
I guess I'll take it
also welcome back unlimited rice pudding
continuing the sub gifts good to see you
okay Life Goes On
not the most Pleasant of games
it's tougher Gambit time
staffer Gambit declined
uh Bishop B4 first
yeah trying to apply a lot of pressure
from early on
Queenie Savanna
so Knight ticks I take here and then
take here
oh there's Rook okay I have this move
though
if I took with Queen there's Brook E1
but thankfully I have similar pin ideas
oh Jules Gambit says I don't think I've
ever seen this after accepted
maybe you weren't watching uh a few
hours ago
I've had a couple nice Safford accepteds
the Stream
but yeah unfortunately Stafford declined
is
probably a little bit more common
okay this should end
very soon
be winning the bishop
now the big question is can I castle
with checkmates
how do I orchestrate at Queen E7
G5
oh no my Pawn
take my Pawn come back
a point wants to play rookie five
which is understandable
I think I'll play this
I have three
wait my time
to move a little bit quicker
yeah it's not over
it should be a pretty straightforward
win
like at some point I'll stock the thing
for the other thing
and then when the king Bond ending yeah
plenty of time
okay
I don't like it when
kings run away from me
I like it when they like if I like it
when they run towards me
otherwise I get lonely
okay uh no berserking
um okay we have a benoni Gambit accepted
yeah this is already a nice line
I don't know why
opponents allowing
I guess I have to be careful though
like maybe it's some playable Gambit
like Knight H figures G6
hmm
Queen D2 Maybe
a little bit awkward
it actually reminds me of a reverse
orthostnop
at some point I'll probably give back
epon
maybe it's close to equal
or maybe I'm still slightly better
because
black has ISO Queen's Pawn
a rifa friendship oh hooray
Kung Fu chess
it was also my Kung Fu friend
yeah the idea is to put the queen on
each four
and his eyes some targets
I don't have Biz about four here
I guess I'll take an rugby one preparing
this
allowing this but then before
I mean what else to do
oh very fancy
get away with like some bishop move
I think Bishop G5
I mean the point is just to defend the
rook and uh eventually move back
also preventing Bishop E7
really
wow
wow wow wow
does this really work
take
some workout one
problem is Rick F1 doesn't work and
there's so few options here
I guess Bishop E3
when the rook's gonna take
and some Queen D4
take take
maybe it's playable
I'm down the pond though
yeah that's not great for me
maybe there's some counter play
oh a poem's offline
maybe they're busy paying on chess.com
oh they're in second place oh wow
maybe they fell asleep it still sells
our online here though
I was just calculating this uh check in
here
not so simple
[Music]
okay that was pretty simple
rook's Moving Straight Lines
okay
hey I've gained back some rating
at some point I was below 2500
I'm still down about 30 points
in this tournament
the berserking doesn't really help
but it's nice when the opponent
blizzards back
oops
how bad is this it's pretty bad
okay let's just pretend it's a gamut
got a little bit too excited there
time to calm down
a deep breath
I like my Pawns
yeah these pawns are wow Worthy
I don't really want to touch them
but maybe I do
that's a pawn Diamond wow
wow
okay
I won back the piece
the pawns were too immaculate
let's play this move
hitting each Pawn offering the queen
trade
hmm
still have to be careful
foreign
can take
oh wow
I hung a rook but no one saw it
wow
oh my king
my beautiful King
oh to do
I think it's the nature of the
tournament like this
like we get so tired and then just start
like throwing mud at each other
okay 20 second place
do I berserk
I'm debating
if I click on the button and hold it
doesn't actually go through
mugs
oh thank you ju ho Jay
cheers
okay we have an anti-catalan
discouraging Z4 C4 is still playable
I've had this position before
um
I guess Bishop A6 happy Wednesday
always Wednesday
happy Wednesday
is there anywhere in the world that's
still
Tuesday
oh yeah California
Hawaii
man it's really late I forgot how time
zones work
oh but in Carolina it's probably
Wednesday
okay so we have um interesting
Dynamic a slightly backward C Pawn
quackity quackity quack quack quack
at the same time I have the C4 Square
welcome back David
yeah a lot of Trades
relatively peaceful so far
I do want to exploit the pawn
I mean White's gonna get play against my
Pawns
all these pawns are potential weaknesses
but all these pawns are also potential
Queens
or potential Knights
okay I think I'm winning a pawn
also thanks so much Sabina
appreciate the raid
shout out Sabina
whoa
I guess that's a move
if I take
we trade a lot
hmm
I I guess I'll go for the trade
well I can dig with either Rook
yeah I think Sabina hope you had a good
stream
again if you're just joining this is a
winter Marathon
it's a 24-hour Blitz tournament
I started streaming about four hours ago
and I kind of missed that move I can't
take the bishop because then I
get mated
um so it's probably worth moving upon
I think the Rook will just come back to
E7
um that's a question
[Music]
yeah if I move it to C2 there's Bishop
C6
I could move it to E5 but let's start
with E7
this could be a long grind
okay the Knight wants to come ideally to
E1
kind of hard to get to though
maybe the king can go to F6
defending the Rook
the rookie six is already playable
I don't think white can make the trade
you know
yeah that's a move
maybe the king can start walking
and King C5
we're seeing Rook B2 or Bishop C6
still not easy
hmm
trying to attack the pollen with my
knight
oh I love B6 though
um how bad is this
this is actually pretty bad or is it
maybe it's not
now this is just fine
okay I'm winning upon
okay it's a draw
oh
yeah I mean it should auto claim a draw
there but uh what to do
oh yeah I love Bishop takes
I should have taken the bishop but okay
[__] game
oh welcome to sorry putat
is new to chess watching videos on
YouTube
welcome
yeah you've joined for a special stream
this is a 24-hour Marathon chess
tournament
and we have I wonder if Jules is still
here we have a Stafford gamut exception
which uh
has been a slightly rare occurrence
I'm not thrilled with the position
already but
it's something
in time is a big factor here
Queens are aligned there's a funny
tactic to take
because the pawn is pinned
wow
I think I'll move back
and now I want to go for checkmates
but it's not so simple
or is it
I mean having the H file is really nice
like there's ideas of taking swinging
over
it might actually work here
as Bishop takes Queen H5 and then
there's a monster battery
hey Jules is still here
okay
so the power of the Stafford exception
Don't Mess except am I getting mated
I don't think I'm getting Maiden why can
soccer Rook for
a few spy checks
oh that move I missed though
I might actually be getting Maiden
oops
I'm in like Pew trouble here
ah stop hurting me
you just call me Eric
how did this pronounce my name
foreign
are you playing to the End Eric
Maybe
also what do I do here
don't hurt me
yeah the monster battery isn't so
monstrous
ah I'm too slow and too weak
oh no good game though
had my chances went a little bit too
insane
yeah Rook H2 wasn't necessary
what to do
still above 2500. 26th Place
Lord ax is crushing it playing
castrosito
I think it's very risky to play soccer
against this person but I haven't lost
this person
in a long time
happy holidays everyone
I think this is my first Grand Master
opponent of the Stream
also happy holidays
take that
so I can see the bishop here
uh yeah that's a good move
my Bishop is kind of stuck
yeah Bishop C4
Knight D5 it's a brave move
well there's a fine line between bravery
and stupidity
six is also
do I have um I have 93
look at this move
93 isn't probably doesn't work but
it's a funny move it leaves my knight in
Queen hanging but White's Queen and
Bishop are hanging
the problem is my knight might get
trapped but no no I'm attacking the rook
in the end
Rook C1
let's see one night before
so this is somehow playable
my son Twisted miracle
or Christmas miracle
oh is my knight actually trapped
I have a F5
oh no I don't have that five what is
this
B5
B5 doesn't really work
H6
oh that's crazy
[Music]
but also kind of sad
it'll just take on E2 and be sad
not resigning because there's still some
idea of F5 and winning the pawn
I have two palms for the piece maybe
soon to be three
G4 could be annoying
okay
I have a four
doesn't trap the bishop though
now I have four
I mean look
ideas to trap the bishop allows it to
have this move
I promise
I'm not threatening to take the bishop
because Knight F7
but it's getting really tricky
I'm throwing H6 and rookie five
oh good move
ah
if I took first I was Knight G6
I still have two pawns for the piece
hmm
try and trade Pawns
I have a bad feeling about this
okay
yeah what to do
I was getting mated
well played
interesting fight though
tried to generate some counter play
oh okay
why always me
playing a lot of Grand Prix attacks
so we have a
I'm a standard position for Grand Prix
some standard attacking ideas
Bishop is maybe a little bit misplaced
especially lights red Bishop
c4's coming
could not afford to allow it
going for G4
maybe I shouldn't just shift attention
to the center
and hang upon
oops
oh no
okay it's still not over
it might be over soon though
I'm trying to fight
like Brooke
how to do this
okay some swindle
foreign
uh not quite
yeah we'll play it what to do
uh created some counter play there it
just wasn't enough the mission got
really bad
gave way too many Pawns
playing the cable box
okay try and get back on a
a non-losing streak
I have a London
have a good record against this player
yeah this is a more positional line
the ventral idea of Knight C1 to D3
okay A5
yeah this is nice this is like the dream
setup
because if ever B6 I take so it's
essentially an outpost
it might be ideas of 95 as well
so if it takes I take that's a fork
foreign
there's an idea of lifting The Rook
yeah so far this is all like very
thematic play
I'm still following like the basic
opening ideas
wow
so if I take
I think I might have to take actually
C4
it's not so simple
I have some time
I'll just tell our five
wow there's a cool line
96 Rook G7 check
don't think it works though
but maybe it does
let's try it
it might not work
but it looks cool
yeah I don't think this works
oh cute
can I play like Knights
and there's so many things I want to do
but they don't really work
in D5
it's desperation but
maybe it'll create some confusion
still not over
and I think anything could happen here
five hangs
got away with taking
probably not
[Music]
um
wait what if I take with Queen
it doesn't work
I'm gonna try something
[Music]
foreign
to do
uh good game I went a little bit
overboard there
it has a safe position to
I wonder if I actually had anything
though
nah
earlier yeah earlier Queen H5 G6
rookie oh rookie four
Knight C3 and then Rook H4 yeah
okay 31st
not my best streak of the tournament
can only improve from here hopefully
okay playing kopachi
never played before
if I'm gonna turn this freak around I
might as well do it
all berserking
I'm still offering a staff right now
Bishop E2
foreign
G5
yeah this is uh like already kind of
imbalanced
but it's an attempt to play aggressively
foreign
let's take
it with Knights versus Bishops
I didn't want to take and run into like
Bishop F3
but taking on e4 is now probably a
threat
Bishop D3 is expected
wow
let's hold off
[Music]
um
at night would be nice on E5
and white was very persistent and
sagging the epon
Queen D4 not playable
this is about to get really confusing
some ideas to play H4
foreign
yeah it was difficult position to hold
things together
ah not enough time to try any tricky
traps
what to do
oh no my losing streak
I was saying it can't get much worse
okay maybe
maybe I should berserk again if I born
back
okay this is a fun line
C5 and
I still go for this
wow
let's go for this
this is kind of risky but risky for both
of us
why always me
this is actually
I have to be really careful here
I think it's like barely okay
that's a good move though
maybe it's not okay
if I take
no this is not okay
don't hurt me
stop hurting me
the E5 and Bishop B4 some counter play
sacking a pawn for a spike check
Knight C3 may be coming I'm not getting
mated because the King has a lot of
breathing room
doesn't need an oxygen tank
at night is almost stuck almost trapped
wow this is changing direction really
quickly
uh check a G5 first
Jack
I'm meeting I'm meeting
Rook G4 checkmate
wow
I don't know how that happened
but I'll take it
oh man
okay and got the berserking points let's
go
the tables are turning
okay yeah this requires Focus
if I'm gonna berserk I have to like
fully immerse myself in the game
Castle
an E5 looks nice
some E6 idea
so H6 is attacked three times
all right my Bishop's pinned
uh how to do this if I take
I don't think taking works
Knight G4 is maybe coming
queen of 4 AM
so it's equal material
Kings tied down to the pawn
Knights tie down to h8
foreign
basically offered a draw there I
basically turned it down
um
that was a great move
I'll try Block's taking time here
like Rook A5 is so obvious
ah good move
Rook H7 was
supposed to be the move
which I do
uh well played
probably should have just repeated bear
A5 was very strong from Black
why do I always play this person because
why always me
okay
[Music]
uh we have appearance
play one of these
yeah this is a fun line
generally
I think you lucky Smalls
so yeah this is generally
[Music]
um
not an easy attack for black to deal
with
at the same time
I have to be really careful not to get
Maiden
I think it's okay
because Queen A3 I have this move and it
takes it's important I can take with
Bishop
I still have some attack too
and G5
yeah threatening Rook H5
oh
I just missed
I completely forgot about that thread
and G5 cut off my queen too
ah what to do
oh no my queen
oh no my king
why always me
okay let's try and uh recover a little
bit
playing hub18
but E5
yeah this is like the Tilt opening
repertoire
um
not my proudest selection of openings
but trying to be aggressive
can take
maybe like Bishop C5
allowing the queen trade
oh wow
yeah bedtime is being postponed
is just a little bit going for rookie
Eights
it's weird to like have traded Queens
but still got a bit of counter play
um
yeah the problem is I'm still down the
pond
95.
now it's my Angry opening repertoire
can control the anger here
I guess we just trade Rooks and I'm down
the pond
uh
uh I'll play this position
the good thing is that whites
majority in the king side is doubled so
it's not easy to make a passer
now it's still a matter of moving
quickly
I'm probably dancing a bit with the
Knights
H4 H5
[Music]
I didn't berserk but I'm still down a
lot of time
um
yeah I just have to hold my ground and
move try and move quicker
so other night wants to come to C7
and B5 here
P5 doesn't work B6
B6 also doesn't work
yeah when it rains it pours
I'm hitting this pond
oh no all my Pawns
yeah you never know
there's sometimes weird stalemates
the problem is there's no like stalemate
trap
because I don't have a king eight
yeah what to do
hey what's up toggy
long time no see
hope you're doing well
okay no more berserking let me try and
not lose another game
we have a Stafford
another Stafford accepted okay so in
this line
uh Knight takes E4
is a cool move
because the phone Jake so I have Bishop
F2
if that I think I can just Castle
castling work
castling's a fancy move it's not
necessary I think I've had this position
before and it's just a matter Bishop D6
but
um that's a fancy way to play
welcome back obese race
happy 28 months
foreign
okay this is a slightly more peaceful
game
time is better does opponent just give
me material
I think so
there's some idea Rook d8 Bishop C3
in Bishop D6 first
I was really close to winning more
material
Queen's attacks
I guess we're just Trading
take the bishop let's take this
threatening Bishop H2
I don't think there is any way to avoid
that
like both Bishops were in danger
okay oh that was not a good move
I thought I had Bishop E6
but then rookie for rookie three
on the bright side I was up so many
pawns that I think it's still okay
but that was really not called for
foreign
at least it's making things interesting
yeah nice thing is I have lots of Pawns
here
and the bishop covers F7 and C6
like almost a meeting idea
thank you
okay so I basically have Bishop in four
pawns for Rook
none of my pawns can really move though
so that's a matter of patience
a king F6
foreign
where
I should probably get some sleep
like it's showing yeah that's not a play
workout for
it's showing a little bit more in the
games
like there's been so many instances in
this ending and I've been so close to
blundering
even this technique oh this is actually
a cool idea
Bishop D1 there we go
oh that doesn't even work
okay I went on time
oh man
hello to jackal
chess is going well a little bit tired
let's not berserk let's try and get a
easier win than usual
oh this is interesting
I think I've had this position before
against the same opponent
so there's an idea to play Bishop C5
also Rook to you nah not Rook T1 Let's
Play Bishop C5
it seems really close to
foreign
actually don't know what's close to
being
but the fact that black cat Castle
E5 is a little bit tender
opponent's playing well though
Bishop D3 could be
problematic
foreign
before
[Music]
actually C4 threads made in one
B3 Bishop B2
the goal is to take the Knight and win
E4 with Chuck
oh no
I thought I was being safe
foreign
oh dear
I think I was being safe
although already here
it's not so simple
because I can't actually defend the Rook
actually Queen G4 is a great move
like maybe off to per Pat
well played
oh no my reading
okay let me try and get out of the rut
maybe I'll try and like get to 200
and then call it the knights
played this opponent earlier
yeah sleep time is approaching
I'm playing C5
there's actually some Theory like each
six is interesting
um can I just take
I'll admit I don't know the theory here
but this looks playable
envision
yeah is it before
like A6
I'm missing a lot of things here
I think it's still okay
but
or is it okay
there should be six Keys seven
foreign
ducky
that you owe my candies
I miss my duck
are all my ducks
okay I'm up upon here
um
the thing is
part of in this
idea
I think what it's going to take
oh it doesn't take wow
okay now it's easier to play for when
but how a bishop
F3
that doesn't work
I have to chase suspicable way like King
C6
maybe Knight C8
not super pretty
I'm not quite trouting the bishop
hmm
there's actually a fascinating position
foreign
[Music]
ideas to put the King on G6
some sleep may help your game yeah
that's actually a good suggestion
how do I get the Knight to D5 maybe like
this
oh no
okay
foreign
's getting really spicy
really
no
I was so proud to find net of six two
because if I don't have Knight F6 it's I
think instantly losing is it still
losing though oh it's still losing no
it's winning no it's losing
wow what a crazy finish
yeah Bishop D4 that's crazy that my
queen is powerless
Queen C4
[Music]
ah what to do okay here's what I'll do
if I lose a game I end the Stream
because I should get sleep
I play is uh
is being affected by my
lack of awakeness
berserk
berserking is a
sign that I really want sleep
or I just really want to get the
berserking points
um yeah this is already a questionable
line for whites
maybe it's viable though
I'm berserking someone over 100 points
higher rated
and their nap is working back
I'll see what I can do
like before
and DNA C3
foreign
which I didn't fully calculate
I can take
and it's just a trade
I'm gonna have some kind of
like Rook H7
foreign
ah
oh so close
I decided to lose
uh just two free moves away
a little bit too slow there
yeah it's hard to remove when all when
there's so many like potential checks
uh with a rook
anyway we uh as we keep going
playing this person again
only played a few times before
this is a line that Hans Neiman played
against report
saw the game nice game from earlier
okay again if I lose the stream ends
almost time to start saying my age in
years
oh let's go
welcome back to cued
uh it's a little bit uncomfortable
foreign
things
should be winning
okay let's go
the stream continues
let me change the stream title
if I lose a game
I end the Stream
there we go
nobody's working playing cable box
ah we played earlier I like the line
that we had earlier Queen B6
yeah I'll repeat this
yeah the previous game I went a little
bit too crazy
hopefully I've learned my lesson
offering some trade here
I still want to go for B4
under attack
yeah I'm not playing the whole
tournaments I mean I lead joy into so
even if I wanted to I I couldn't really
mm-hmm
yeah we're getting a very similar thing
to what we had earlier where I went a
little bit too crazy
on
the king side
I mean there's some potential sacks like
it's so tempting
let's start with the oh no okay at least
wait
my muscles up
take take
I do have Rook takes
foreign
just allow the simple Fork
but the night for now is almost as
strong as a rook
ain't not as quiet
so can we have six Rick have seven ideas
I really want to play rogoff seven
it doesn't work though
some Queen E5 idea
yeah this might lead to something F6 I
take on E6
king of seven Knight G5
I have broke off six here
foreign
G7 96
it's insane there's rookie eight in that
line
wow rookie Queen V8s so Queen G7 96
rookie a queen B8
I take I'm up a pawn in the end
the crazy line
there's no other like great way to stop
okay shades
and that the resulting Rook ending still
isn't so simple to win but
I mean but the time situation it should
be a
pretty straightforward win
yeah if I took the queen I would have
done mated
foreign
ending should be winning
go for this
okay
I'll take it
I allowed the fork that game but fought
back
so the stream continues
somehow someway
I'm not gonna berserk I want this stream
to go on at least one more game
okay playing this line
good morning from Vienna good night to
Saint Louis hope you have a good stream
uh technically good morning from St
Louis too
I'm sad to say it's 2 A.M
but also soon to be good night because
I'm gonna be sleeping soon
thank you Max
okay that's a very classic situation of
a
minority attack
this is
basically the dream
now the question is
how to keep applying pressure
and Rook C4
allowing B3
B3 myself
okay this first
some threat of uh Rook D4
or D4 doesn't work though
I don't know why I wanted to play that
maybe I'll triple up
now Rook D4
yeah like G5
G5 works
well you could play G4
and then F5
it's still not over after King G3 oh
King G3 I would take
I don't think there's perpetual
okay let's see if I can end the stream
above 2500.
making some Headway
keep it going berserk that's risky
berserking win rate has not been good
recently
okay C4
interesting
hmm
foreign
not immediately winning with attack
oh no
I was uncalled for
this could be the final game
uh it's going to take a lot of work to
come back here
okay thankfully getting this move in
I forgot six
it's not so easy to break through though
uh
allow that to
it's actually a really fascinating
position
[Music]
foreign
.
to take
but each is covered
hmm
draw
don't really want to draw here though
but maybe my opponent doesn't want one
either
foreign
just in the nick of time
the stream continues
okay
I'm moving up in the world
actually kind of staying in the same
place
playing Vision chess
that was a wake-up call
I'm gonna go for this funny plan
of like Bishop Queen B1 Bishop H7
sometimes a idea
maybe H3
I'm waiting for Bishop f8
I allowed Bishop F3
I don't know what to do
foreign
hitting the D6 Pawn now
okay black finally cracks a little bit
foreign
[Music]
first
oh maybe it's not great
What's Happening Here
foreign
[Music]
it's actually really interesting though
there's gonna be some zugzvong
eventually I think
hopefully it's not me
uh this could be the last game
foreign
okay
that was the last game
oh what a cool position though
like we were both kind of stuck I should
have just moved upon
but I guess black can always move back
and forth and then I'm
short on moves okay it's time for me to
uh get some sleep
thanks everyone for watching hopefully
I'll be back tomorrow or later today
to finish the tournament
so I really need sleep